you have to fight to reach your dream
you have to sacrifice and work hard for
it
that's coming from the man who has come
to define natural talent
but that's what other people put on him
people want to see somebody who's just
naturally talented it's god-given they
were graced they were blessed with
something at birth
but what does he say when he's asked
about what it took to become the person
that he is
it took hard work it took sacrifice it
took giving things up it took doubling
down it took pushing himself every day
day after day and that's the thing about
hard work
when you put that kind of unending
blinding effort into something it gets
to the point where you've worked so hard
that it looks like magic that people
would sooner believe that it's dna that
it's gifted that it is god-given than to
believe
that they would have to work that hard
to replicate it but if you can stop
making other people extraordinary as a
way to let yourself off the hook then
you too can become extraordinary all of
us are capable of far more than we think
we're capable of more than the people
who love us the most think we are
capable of more than the people who hate
us the most would have us believe
at the end of the day
it is a very simple question you're
going to have to ask yourself
and answer for yourself
how hard are you willing to work
how much are you willing to sacrifice
but on the other side of that is power
and energy and as kyle rhode jr said if
you're attacking you don't get as tired
as when you're chasing
and that's the key
when you
know what you want and when you will not
be held back from getting it suddenly
you go on the offensive it's not about
pleasing somebody else it's not about
chasing somebody else becoming them or
even beating them it is about yourself
knowing what you want and attacking it
going after it and not letting anybody
dissuade you it is looking at yourself
and recognizing how you have to improve
to get that good but you've got to
hunger for that goal you've got to
hunger to get across and win you've got
to want that
the way that a man whose head is on fire
wants a pond
and when you get to that stage when
you're able to cultivate something in
yourself like that something that is
refusing to be extinguished something
that will be heard something that will
stand up and be counted
then you're going to have what you need
to get the skills that you need to move
forward to win to attack and in that
attack and having the energy to move
forward relentlessly
you will find that even though you're
working harder than you've ever worked
in your life
you're more energized than you've ever
been in your life
the times where you fatigue
they're not the times you're working the
hardest
the times you fatigue are when you're
being leased yourself
you're not being true to who you are and
what you want
so right now
right now
start being honest about what it is
you're willing to attack
start being honest about who you want to
be what you're willing to become and the
price you're willing to pay to get there
if you give yourself over to that
you will not be able to be stopped i
know that every single one of us
procrastinates me too so it's okay
the issue is can you set yourself up so
you do less of it
i believe you can you're more likely to
do something
if you have already prepared
and stepped it through
you're already more likely to do
something if you already prepared and
stepped it through what does that mean
it means if you want to
not procrastinate on monday
sunday night i want you to sit down and
do this simple little thing
project plan
i know it's not sexy please don't make
fun of me right now it's not sexy i know
it's not sexy and it will change your
life forever
the day before
the days in which it's required that you
really get stuff done i want you to sit
down
and project plan i don't mean tomorrow
write down your to-do lists that is one
element of project planning
but i want a bigger picture i want you
to be thinking about the big projects
that you have coming up and i want you
to have written out
these steps that it's going to take the
big steps that we'll take to accomplish
this project and this project and this
project with a timeline for each of them
and then work backwards from that to
create tomorrow's to-do lists
but here's what's funny
if listen to this if your mind can't see
completion
if your mind cannot see completion
meaning you don't know the path
you don't have clarity
on the path to fulfill or complete
something if your mind can't see the
steps
your heart will ask to pause knowing
your next three steps
is not enough
your mind needs to see
all the steps through to completion and
that's what we call project planning
it's not super fun but it's saying okay
this is the big project here are the big
key activities the big buckets of
activities
that would have to happen to get it done
here's the timelines those big buckets
have to happen okay then these big
buckets of activities those have been
broken down into tasks
and then into ultimately daily to do's
and if we don't have that like it's just
hard to act when you don't have a
complete picture
right you're kind of like uh
procrastinating what i do to avoid
procrastination each week
is every single sunday for me that's my
sunday review days sunday work days i'll
sit down and i'll literally step through
the entire week of all the major things
on my email or on my to-do list
i'll think about the bigger projects
and i'll just kind of step it all the
way through
and guess what
i enter the week
more engaged
more joyous and confident because i know
what the heck is going on
so if you keep procrastinating i promise
if it's not lots of worry or it's not
you know lots of randomness it's you
haven't seen it through yet self-love is
no longer about pleasure or having a car
it's something that you're cultivating
within you so then imagine we have
research to show and this is such a this
is such a
duality
that when you start seeing the brain
start synchronizing getting coherent the
front of the brain on the back of the
brain that two hemispheres coming
together and you we can say to
scientists that come and study our work
oh watch this ed's gonna pop what do you
mean just watch this is gonna be good
and all of a sudden you see this brain
going into this kind of psychic union
the heart blows wide open you see
coherence going on and you look around
at that person and there's tears running
down their face
imagine feeling so whole
that it's impossible to want i mean how
can you want when you're whole because
you feel like you already have it now
when you reach that point
that's when the magic happens because
now you are worthy to receive and the
universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving share this
with them please yeah i think you know
for me i mean
um
i'm curious and i'm a pragmatist i mean
if you tell me something all i want to
know is how i'm going to use it in my
life yes and i'm not in the dinner
conversation because nobody changes from
that you know i mean i'm a doer and i
want to be around doers and and that's
why you and i connect so well i think
and i yeah yeah obviously and and
and uh
you you create a group of people
that are passionate about transformation
and they've they've done some of the
work when we were doing our four day
four and a half day uh advanced
workshops right around the end of the
event i was seeing people starting to
notice seeing some really great
transformations and i thought this is
the pop yeah it's a pop yeah big pops
yeah and we were like we had to send
them home
and i was like oh god man if i could
just have them for a week
so we created these week-long events
where people retreat from their lives
and
they remove the constant stimulation in
their external environment that reminds
them of who they think they are as a
personality yes they separate themselves
from the people they know and the places
they go and the things that they do at a
certain amount of time in their routine
mundane life so we'll bridge a little
quantum physics with a little neural
science little
endocrinology a little epigenetics
psychoneuroimmunology those are all
sciences about possibility and i now
know that if you can give people sound
scientific information
and you know
for me that's the language
and then if they can turn to the person
next to them and explain it you're not
going to get off the hook
if you can't explain it it's not wired
in your brain but if you can build a
model and explain it you're installing
the neurological hardware in your brain
in preparation for the experience so the
more you understand what you're doing
and why
how it gets easier because you can
assign meaning to it so then if i can
set up the conditions in the environment
and give them the proper instructions
and push the envelope a little bit yeah
and people who get their behaviors to
match their intentions and their actions
equal to their thoughts they get their
mind and body working together
they're gonna have a new experience and
the experience then is not only going to
enrich the philosophical circuits in the
brain because experience does that but
it's going to produce an emotion so
they're going to start feeling more
unlimited i have been practicing this
habit
for
a little over a year and it all began in
april of 2020 and this is not something
that i was like okay i got to write a
book it's got to have a five in it it's
gonna be five years since i've written a
book thank you dyslexia and adhd what am
i gonna write about what am i that's not
how this happened the high five habit
saved me
it was a ladder that helped me climb out
of a hole i had fallen into emotionally
physically spiritually and
a year later
after practicing what is going to sound
like a weird
stupid thing
which you will resist and jay you and i
are going to unpack this because it's
sad why everybody resists it
it has to do with the dust that's
accumulated
and i will tell you after a year
of practicing this
i don't even see
a face or a body
i see a soul
i don't even have to high-five myself i
still do because it feels good and we're
gonna explain the science that is
bananas about why this actually works
for everybody who tries it
because this is not something that's new
you are tapping into programming that's
already in your mind and body and now
directing it back at yourself it's
incredible
i
don't ever criticize myself
i don't ever see what's wrong i see a
human being who's trying
who deserves love and respect and i know
that it's my job to give it to her
you know the five second rule which i
created i don't know over a decade ago
that's gone on to help me change my
whole life it's a little starting ritual
and a brain hack that you can use to
help yourself take the actions and
change the thoughts that change your
life
it helped me be more productive it
helped me get stuff done
the high five habit has changed who i am
it has deleted a lifetime of criticism
and negativity from my mind and it has
reprogrammed the soundtrack to be
somebody that's supportive and a
cheerleader
it's extraordinary at the end of
your day or week do you ever find
yourself
worried or frustrated because no matter
how much effort you put in to work and
no matter how hard you work your
financial situation
and your financial future may never seem
to be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now
with not a lot of breathing room and i
would imagine no discretionary income or
even time to spend on the little things
that really would make your life more
enjoyable well what i can share with you
is you're not alone that's number one
and in most cases
the real problem
is not your current circumstances
what the real problem is that most
people repeat the same
patterns of thought
and behaviors over and over again
and that is the cause
of what more of the same results but
they are looking for different results
and so today i'm going to show you how
to break that pattern break that cycle
now you see when you think of your
results your results are effects
and so the question is effects of what
and the answer is your results are all
effects of what you believe to be true
about yourself what you believe to be
true that is possible
and
it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now
if you think about what you believe and
if you think about your habits that is
what is causing the effect that you may
not like right now and so a simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if i could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and i
could create more empowering habits
then my result will change
and what i love to focus on having done
an enormous amount of brain research
over the last 10 years is something
called your inner game
and your inner game
is comprised of obviously your beliefs
your attitude your perceptions how you
see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action
and so let me share just a little story
with you that may help you understand
what i mean
about two years ago i was at a seminar
and when i got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and i could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and i saw tears
streaming down her eyes
and when she got through the crowd
for a moment i thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes
and when i met her her name was joni
sanderson and this was in perth
australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and i go well for what
she says well
about a year ago i heard you speak about
beliefs
and habits and mastering my emotions and
really working on my self-worth and she
said to me that she was a caregiver and
that she loved helping families who
needed
extra assistance for their aging parents
or for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a widow's pension of about 12 000
aussie dollars a year and so she really
didn't have enough money to be able to
take the care of her grandkids that she
wanted to to be able to take her
children on a vacation and so i shared
with her why do you think that you're
only earning twelve thousand dollars a
year and she said i don't know and when
i shared with her that she possibly
believed that that's what she was worth
and she said to me well i think i'm
worth more i said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level
of your brain
you have this feeling that maybe you're
not smart enough or not good enough or
not worthy enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior
and so what i helped joanie do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was i helped her recognize
that beliefs drive behavior
beliefs drive emotions habits drive
behavior and in order to change your
results living paycheck to paycheck
being stressed out worrying about your
future or even your present
circumstances right now
why not focus on working on the neural
patterns the beliefs and habits that are
nothing more than patterns in the brain
that drive 96 to 98
of your behavior and so she started to
work on what i call a belief and habit
modification program and while she did
this she started to see herself in a
different light she started to feel more
confident more certain and more
empowered and what i can share with you
is she at that moment told me that she
went for making twelve thousand dollars
a year as a widow's from a widow's
pension and living paycheck to paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
as she was making 75 000
a year first of all i don't like the
term failure i like the term falling i
think you need
we we fail fast well
the problem with the word fail is it's
like the word cancer right
if you have stage four lung cancer or
stage four liver cancer and you have a
mild melanoma
with a 99.999 chance of you'll be fine
both of those things are called cancer
and the problem is they're not the same
thing and failure's the same is the same
which is failure could be absolutely
catastrophic or it could be a minor
hiccup but the problem is we call it
failure so i think we need to use
different terms right failure i believe
is something we want to avoid but
falling is something that happens
naturally and we want to fall and get
get up more often that's what i think is
fall fall fast and get yourself back up
as opposed to lying on the ground and
complaining right so i i want to embrace
falling because that's that's taking
risks that's trying you only fall when
you push the boundaries right
but the the the the language matters
because it changes our mindset
especially because it's too broad of
definition for failure
so one of the ways we embrace falling
is by when somebody does fall
we don't say what have you done we go
okay try again as leaders
right um or um how can i help you fix it
and we just a little more relaxed about
it and and we don't swoop in and do it
for them right
but rather we go
so in other words we're encouraging
risk-taking we're encouraging people to
try recognizing that they won't lose
their jobs
that
that
especially if you're more junior you
really couldn't do anything that brings
down the firm anyway
and we have to give people the
opportunity to fall and let them either
learn to fix their own problems or guide
them so that so that they can every
single one of us has screwed up a
bazillion times and the only reason we
are where we are today is because
somebody said all right all right you're
an idiot but try again you know
like that's where i know who did it for
me peter and maggio my old boss years
and years and years ago the guy would
never answer any of my questions peter
what should i do what do you think we
should do like
if i knew i wouldn't be asking well what
do you think i think we should do this
then do that the guy never answered a
question and if i screw up he goes
what are you going to do
you know
but i never felt fear that i would get
fired ever
i never felt afraid that my job was on
the line when i screwed up
we have to do that for people my
grandfather said something to me that
i i say it's the reason i'm successful
and i love to
tell young people this you know we've
spoken at harvard notre dame some of the
top schools in the country and
i always say this and he asked me what
are you going to do i said
i'm the janitor i have to mop the floor
he looked at me and he said when you mop
that floor
you make sure that it shines so when
people see it they know that a mountain
has mocked it
and my dad said listen to your grandpa
you know i actually took that on
and this is what i tell people and you
know maybe some people will get it in
somewhat i said as much as i love the
compensation the promotions frito-lay
hot cheetos pepsi the truth is
it was never about them
it was always about my last name
you know it was always about that you
know and uh
i'm mopping the best i could and i saw
that i was having an influence
and people say how can you have an
influence when you're just a janitor
and i told people there's no such thing
as just a janitor when you believe in
your heart you're going to be the best
no such thing as a waiter a bus driver
and what was happening was
my job was to clean the bathrooms the
lunchroom and all the uh
managers
offices before they came in in the
morning
so the workers would go into the
bathroom and the bathroom was spotless
it smelled good and they come out with a
smile like hey
who who cleaned that and then they go
into the lunchroom and it was you know
spotless now you know i wasn't
complaining like throw your own trash i
was just cleaning and smell good
and then in the morning the managers
were you know opening up their offices
and saying wow who
my office is spotless who you know who
did this and everybody pointed
to that janitor and said richard
montenez and that's when i learned that
at a very young age that i had an
influence
i could influence people without saying
one word
by my work ethics i i influenced i put a
smile on their face and never even said
anything and then i realized too you
know some of these quotes quote that are
ancient exactly that they're ancient
somebody said
you get promoted by who you know
i said that's not true you get promoted
by who knows you you can say you know
the ceo or the manager all you want but
if they don't and that's what was
happening
as a janitor people were knowing who i
was just because of my work ethics i
hadn't even spoken a word yet i've
talked to so many people who say well
you know i got to i must become an
expert before i go out there and launch
my business i must become an expert
before i go out there and
whatever write that book create that
movie launch that movement
well
every amateur every professional was
once an amateur and every master was
once a beginner right
and so please remember there will never
be a better time to step into
the performance and the human being
you've always wanted to be
than today
one of the greatest pitfalls i've seen
in having worked with so many people
over a quarter of a century teaching
leadership and elite performance
is that people postpone
their greatness and their eminence to
some distant time in the future when
they're going to have more time and the
stars will align and that is one of the
greatest mistakes that you could
possibly make we don't know what
tomorrow is going to bring
right and you do not want to be one of
those people who
on the last day of their lives they were
full of regret because they couldn't
they didn't do what they knew they could
have done
you are worthy every single there are no
extra people on the planet today every
single one of us
is born into a unique genius only you
have the fingerprints you have only you
have the characteristics you have only
you have the strengths that you have you
are so unique on a planet of how many
billions of people
the the thing that happens is we lose
our confidence as we get hurt and
disappointed by life and a lot of us
what we do is we shut down and we
contract and we protect our once tender
open hearts versus going out into the
arena and sharing our gifts in full
blazing glory please do not think you
are unworthy
of
domain dominance please don't think
you're unworthy of because of
becoming best in the world at what you
do if you sacrifice train learn work
with mentors find the right talent hub
and then optimize your craft every
single day until you reach best in the
world a lot of talk these days about
legacy you know work in a way that
leaves a legacy
uh 22 years ago i wrote a book called
who will cry when you die and it was all
about legacy and back then i was
34 years old long time ago
and i used to talk so much about legacy
you know live in a way that
you live in the hearts that you leave
behind that's really the answer
now
with a little grizz white grizzle
uh
i don't think legacy matters i think
legacy is like trying to get your name
on a hospital wing or a monument built
after you i think it's a pursuit of the
ego
the real key is not to worry much about
how you'll be remembered but the real
key i suggest to you with great love and
respect is living fully and greatly
while you are alive
because once you're dead you're dead
you're just a pile of dust
what did
the benevolent and great roman general
and warrior and emperor
marcus aurelius
alexander the great was buried next to
his stable boy
we don't matter after we've we're gone
so
i don't think you should i think it's
such a myth to be concerned about legacy
if you're trying to live a world-class
life
worry about being world-class while
you're alive be concerned with
optimizing your craft while you have a
beating heart
be concerned with caring for the
brothers and sisters on this little
planet and standing for honesty honor
grace and love
leave every person you meet better than
you found them
and the irony is if you do that you will
leave a legacy even though it's not your
intention a lot of people don't read
because they're afraid of books
the books aren't their friend so you
might want to get a few books and kind
of make them your friend
um
you can start with
simpler books you know like fiction
there's lots of good fiction written for
adolescents and children
it's pretty straightforward you can
start there
if you're interested in philosophy
there's lots of
simple guides like the idiot's guide to
um
different topics or a beginner's guide i
read those things all the time when i'm
first investigating a new topic
you know i start with the introductory
material
um and i make time for reading like
and it was that was encouraged in my
family like i always read before i went
to sleep i read
and i i still do that
um
somewhat less so because i've become so
distracted by social media
but uh
you set aside a bit of time every day to
read and for me it was always just
before i went to bed i go to bed turn
the light and read for when i was a kid
for hours but
and if you do something every day you do
a lot of it and so i would say well if
you want to read if you want to make
yourself educated just put aside
20 minutes a day to read or 10
you know some small amount of time that
you could actually steal not two hours
because good luck man
it's very unlikely you'll manage that
but 20 minutes a day
you know that's
two hours a week that's 700 hours a year
you know that's
even if you're a slow reader that's a
good number of books
and so you make it a habitual part of
your life and you decide that it's going
to be something that you value you
investigate carefully what resistances
you might have to that idea because you
might think well that's
uh
pseudo-intellectual or
there's something more productive i
could be doing or i'm intimidated by
books or i hate books because i wasn't
good at reading when i was a kid and was
humiliated because of it or you know
you've got something against
intellectuals or
god there might all sorts of resistances
to picking up a book then you could
listen to audiobooks that's a good way
around that by hooker by crook man
so
you value it you make it a regular part
of your life you practice doing it and
and you you need a higher goal too is
like well why should you read
well
it's so that you're more informed and
you can think better
why should you be more informed and
think better because you won't walk
blindly into so many
pits you know you'll be able to
negotiate better in your life because
you'll be more
informed
and more verbally fluent and you'll have
a better sense of how the world works
and be able to hold your own in
conversations and that'll make you more
confident those are all unbelievably
good reasons
to be highly literate is is an
incredibly
massive massive advantage
practical advantage you know and it
shouldn't be underestimated i set a goal
in 1973
i set a goal that i was going to build a
company and upgrade all over the world
i had uh left the night yale cornet
corporation
and decided that i was going to do this
because i didn't agree with the way they
were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
and they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so i decided i would leave and start my
own company
and i wrote down i'd build a company and
operate all over the world i got a call
last night from mikey about nine o'clock
something like that
and then she told me
that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of that
we had a broadcast going on here at 10
o'clock this morning
some of you'd be familiar with some of
you may have been on it
and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that move
meant this is really accurate today
we're only limited by weakness of
attention and poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised i don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
is called a terror barrier
the way i'm going to explain this to you
i come up with sitting in a restaurant i
remember it was at a holiday inn
restaurant it was at dixie and
just south of the 401 highway
in toronto
a man asked me if i would meet with him
he had a problem
and
i was going to show him how he could
solve the problem
and he explained it so i took a pen and
some paper and what i'm going to show
you here is essentially what i showed
him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through
when you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
freedom
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier
and then to freedom people ask my wife
all the time what's something about tony
that nobody knows and she says the level
he prepares so that was ray dalio i know
i got a chance to be with literally the
da vinci of investing most average
people never heard his name but right
you have to have a 10 years ago she had
a 5 billion net worth and you had to
give him 100 million to start with for
him to talk to you right today he won't
talk to you and take your money how much
money you have he's he's closed his fund
out he won't he won't do a dime more so
to do that
i i couldn't i couldn't consciously walk
in and just say okay i've read
everything it's available i had to watch
every video there's only a few out there
i had to read every piece i had to like
tear it apart and see if i could
understand his entire structure of
investing so that when i was there i
could ask questions no one else was
asked before and as a result he actually
shared with me he's averaged a 23 return
for 21 straight years
billions and billions and billions of
dollars smartest man one of the smartest
man alive in that area and because i
understood so much we could pitch and
catch you know most people you know you
can just they just they can just throw
the ball right but i need i want to be
able to throw the ball and have you
throw it to me and throw it right back
to you right that's where we get
something that's really exciting and
because i prepared that level he was
saying to me afterwards he goes you know
this better than anybody i know and he's
so it opened him up more and he talked
to me in more detail in the end he
actually gave me a strategy
that i said to him i said look i said
ray
i said you're one of the most generous
men i know
i said you've just given me this
incredible strategy but the strategy was
like explaining why most people lose
money and here's how he's made money in
every market right pretty complex
strategy and i said the strategy is
great but it's kind of like you told me
you want to build a chocolate cake get
some chocolate you know get some sugar
you can tell me the amounts i mean the
amounts are everything right you get the
right amounts and he goes tony i can't
give you that that's my secret sauce and
i said ray you can give it to me because
i can't he goes that's my that's what i
get you know that's why you know i get
the money i do i said no you don't you
haven't taken money for 10 years
i said you're going to give away half
your net worth anyway i said you just
got done telling me the average guy is
never going to do this help me out give
me your secret sauce right and i got him
laughing he goes well tony it's kind of
complex i said i'm going to take complex
and making it simple he goes well i use
leverage i said create one without
leverage so the average guy could do it
right and then i got this chilled on the
back of my spine when he said well it
wouldn't be perfect i said your idea not
perfect it's better than anybody else on
earth i said right tell me and then i
took out a pen and i said tell me the
numbers right he looked at me goes
well let's try this and he starts to lay
this thing out so when i'm done i can
feel the vibration in my body like i got
something nobody's got that i can give
to the world that'll be extraordinary
and i go he goes go test that he goes
don't when people talk about testing
they look back five years or ten years
he said
but the past doesn't equal the future
that way but if you were to test
something over 75 years the entire
modern time of history that's what you
should test that formula back test it
for 75 years come back tell me what you
get
85 of the time it's for 75 years think
of how much the world has changed the
last 10 years or 20 years 85 percent of
the time it makes money the 15 percent
of the time it didn't
the maximum drawdown in 75 years was not
20 like you've seen at 30 or 40 you've
seen in the marketplace over the years
3.9
the average loss is 1.7
average gain is 10 so if you could go to
vegas and you could be right 85 of the
time and when you lost only lose you
know one percent 1.7
how you'd be you'd be investing a little
bit you'd be gambling a little bit right
so he gave that to me so i got those
types of things because i was so
prepared and so when i go to do an
audience a big audience like i do my
date with sd seminar people do 20 pages
of homework and i read all that for a
couple thousand people i won't remember
their faces i remember it's in my brains
once somebody stands up something inside
me recognizes the pattern or recognize
this the pattern that multiple people in
the room need to deal with and my brain
clicks in and makes it happen so i
believe
you know garbage and garbage out as
simplistic as it is that if you keep
putting unbelievable quality amount in
when it's time for you to cash that
spiritual emotional
physical financial business check and
ain't to bounce because you've been
making deposits and you have plenty to
give you're not you're not just winging
it to see what happens so i'm intense
about that but i also love it because it
just i'm always growing too because i'm
always learning more than i need to
teach anybody else you got to commit
first when you know something's right
folks commit
commit
go all in on the deal nobody knows what
you're what you're up to nobody knows
what's going on inside me i called my
mom that night and i said i met my wife
today and she's like
have you all been out where did y'all go
what did you do i said no she hates me
and she's like she hates you grant it
takes two and this is what i knew from
being in business and if you're taking
notes it might be worthwhile it does not
take two to tango
it does not take two to make a marriage
and it does not take a buyer and a
seller what it takes is you
it needs to be you first you have to
decide they're selling the house and you
got to decide that they're buying the
house before any house makes a
transaction i had to decide that she was
going to be the girl before she could
see that i was going to be the guy you
guys with me all right 26 phone calls
all of them were like hey how you doing
you know i didn't mention that she never
calls me back
i didn't mention that she was breaking
my heart every time she didn't call me i
didn't mention the fact that her best
friend said i was too short
okay
you guys know what all your objections
are don't you like her a friend said
you're too short i said just tell me
what the real deal is i got to know what
the objection is i cannot handle the
unspoken objection what is the real deal
grant you're too sharp i said okay what
else what else you got uh you're not a
hollywood guy she's she's an actress i
wasn't in hollywood i'm not an actor
okay good what else you're a businessman
she thinks you're too conservative okay
what else what else you got well you
don't have a prison record
you don't have a prison record no
tattoos she like bad boys okay how many
ladies here like the bad boys
just be honest
okay be honest the lady over here is
like yes
i love them okay so so i just continue
to pursue her because like somebody said
earlier sometimes people change
how many of your room have changed
how many of you have changed
exactly you're going to keep changing
too some of you you're not going to like
so so
i pursued her until one day because i
know this okay and you might want to
keep this in your collection of how you
handle uh discouragement along the way
when you get a no would you agree that
no is a version of yes
how many would agree with that
dude look i mean think about it what's
the opposite of yes
what's the opposite of no
what's in between
maybe
so i always tell people when they tell
me no i'm like don't say no
say maybe
okay just say maybe well maybe grant
maybe but not right now excellent
because i know no's can turn into yeses
i said no to a lot of things in life and
then done them you've walked into a
casino before i am not gambling tonight
i will not gamble you came down to cabo
i am not drinking while i'm here
okay you some of you came down no
enriched bread while i'm here
no
chips no guacamole nothing okay and as
soon as you got down here you're just
like freaking hitting shots
eating guacamole slamming it in your
face right
so how do you get from no to yes
just show up in cabo
it's a maybe
right how do you get somebody to say go
go from not selling their house to yes i
will
get to a maybe
and then follow them up your mind
responds to the pictures and words the
fastest way to change anything is to
change the pictures and words
and it's such an easy thing to do
i'm terrified i'm elated i'm useless i'm
amazing i have no memory my memory is
compelling i can't speak to people what
i have to say
is easy i find it easy to speak to
anyone
this is the most vexing rule of the mind
for every therapist and coach in the
room it's the one my clients have the
hardest time with
your mind loves what is familiar if your
mind could choose it would stay with
what's familiar and never go to what's
unfamiliar we're in a walled city
and that's interesting because years ago
at night they shut the door and we
stayed in the wall we didn't think do
you know i feel like going for a
midnight stroll i think i wonder i'm a
bit bored of being in this same old same
old i want some variety i think i'll
open the gate wander off and find
another tribe they might have killed you
or eaten you
we learnt familiar made us safe who here
notices with their kids and they
literally want the same cup
the same bowl the same cereal i took my
daughter to finland to see santa claus
she watched a little mermaid and
finished the whole time and she didn't
that was okay and finished because she
knew she'd watched it 110 times where
i'm like babe his father christmas is
only mummy i want to watch the little
mermaid it's like well next time we'll
just stay home and watch a movie then
she did actually get into it but it made
her feel good she used to play this game
she had so many barbies and ken would
come up in his car and he was picked the
same one he never picked another one to
go to the ball because they like
familiar it makes them safe you know how
many kids yeah they want the same story
every night
but familiar also makes us safe so
here's a rule of the mind and it's a
very important rule to put into practice
my mind likes what is familiar and it
doesn't like what's unfamiliar okay
but i can make anything negative
unfamiliar and anything positive
familiar let's start with praise it's
the most simple but the most powerful i
meet clients who are never praised i met
one girl whose dad said you're so
rubbish just like your mother
god knows what you've got going if any
man asks you out snap them up because
you are nothing you're not interesting
you're not attractive when you get
pregnant you'll blow up just like her
and be a big fat mess so if anyone wants
to be with you i can't imagine why take
them
and she heard that a lot so she had this
interestingly if i've got nothing to
offer the world and i did a lot of work
with her and she went out she went was
just amazing it was like magic this guy
came up and he asked me out and he was
so nice i mean actually made another
date and he picked me up in his car and
took me out for dinner told me i was
amazing i'm never seeing him again i'm
not really sure no no he was too good
for me i'm like oh
let's change that wording to his
behavior was so unfamiliar
i don't recognize praise or nicest of
somebody believing i'm worth something
and i want to run back to the familiar
guys i have to beg to take me out or
seeing my friends i pay the bill and
they remind me of my dad and i'm like
well guess what you're not supposed to
have sex with your dad so there's a clue
if someone is like your dad i don't
think you should be getting into bed
with them and i think you need to make
that unfortunate people like it when you
make them laugh so she went right so i
said you need to go out with this guy
and this is what you do you keep saying
i will make this familiar he rings me
when he says he will and make it
familiar he texts me i'll make it
familiar i will make it familiar and she
ended up marrying him she's very happy
how weird the other guy called me and
said what happened to me she went what
the guy who never called me you never
called me so i just let you go
so you have to say
let's do it with all of you how many of
you find praise a little unfamiliar
how many of you find praising yourself
even more unfamiliar
okay so if you're never praised and
you're criticized a lot and christmas is
familiar when someone goes wow i love
that teacher i got it free it's got a
hole in it i've had it eight years i
loved your speech didn't you notice i
missed out the best bit no i thought it
was amazing i hear you're the best
salesperson in your team
yeah but not in my county there's
another guy way better than me so if
praise isn't familiar you will reject
praise but
you'll add in what's really a criticism
so the one of the best things you can do
that will change your life
is to make praising yourself familiar
and to make criticism unfamiliar one of
the things that is lacking
with so many people is getting enough
sleep
very basic but make sure
you
know your body like observe it and
explore
many times we hear you need eight hours
of rest well what what does that even
mean
is it quality rest is it the length of
time that matters but for you observe
and explore your body and what works for
you
disclosure for me is before becoming a
monk i always struggled with sleep i
would take
melatonin and i would take benadryl
because it would take me so long to fall
asleep and to stay asleep but i was
doing that and i relied on it for about
four years
uh one of the tips that i learned here
in thailand was that like um learn how
to sleep correctly
um a tip that they gave us and that we
learned in the monastery was your
bedroom
is for sleep
one of the things and think of your
bedroom but one of the things people do
is when you go into their bedroom they
have their computer
they eat there
they work there they talk on the phone
they lay down but it's all types of room
but make sure clean it up a bedroom
should just be to sleep a bed
a pillow
and it's time to sleep so that's a first
step uh a second piece to it
is
one thing that i learned is so many
times throughout the day we're doing so
much good for the world we're always
developing we're always giving
even throughout the week
we do a lot of good
so then recollect it feel good again
for me just being a monk
that feels amazing to me so recollect
that proud feeling if you guys helped
out a co-worker
remember that close your eyes and really
take the time to see
ah that really feels good and holds that
feeling
um any other good if you
help to volunteer if you help the
homeless if you called your mom if you
help the people in this room just
helping each other helping the guests
having lunch together all these proud
feelings that
is collected throughout the day
put it at your center
sleep with that for me i used to always
use the end of the night to think about
my problems and i would reflect
what were the issues of the day
what are the issues of the week and then
what do i need to think about tomorrow
so my mind was always active and being
in the monastery they taught me that's
not the place
because your last thought of the evening
is going to be your first thought in the
morning so learn how to sleep correctly
but when you go to bed
go to sleep lay down
close your eyes
and really recollect the good deeds
think of all the good things you did
today think of all the good things you
did this week think of all the good
things you did in this lifetime and
allow it
allow the proud feeling to just expand
and cover your body just like this bear
cover yourself with this
call it merit field
merit blanket but it's just a pure
whiteness
pure brightness that re-energizes you so
just imagine yourself
being covered with this
pure goodness and sleep in that
and if you can sleep in that it
recharges you when you wake up you're
fully refreshed and you're ready to go
this is the one tip for me with sleep
that changed my whole life and since
then
i haven't
had to take any benadryl and no sleep
aid none of that stuff and i can go to
sleep right away and i wake up refreshed
and fulfilled so sleep
is very important being a biologist i
want to talk about a different aspect of
service but it's the same thing because
my dear friend savage was talking about
service and how we can influence the
world around us i want to give you an
interesting biological insight about
your own personal consequence of being
in service
and basically
it has to do with the dna in your cells
i say what does that mean i say well
the dna is the genetic code i say and
every time the cell divides
you have to copy that code
and so if i can try to make an image
with my hand here imagine my arm is the
dna
and i say it's time to copy it
there's a protein so let's say the
microphone okay thank you that my arm my
hand is the copying device it's like a
train on a railroad track
as the train moves down the dna it
leaves behind a copy of the dna it just
rode over
i say well that's really cool except
guess what when the train gets to the
end of the dna
it can't copy the part where the train
is sitting on it so it copied everything
all the way up to here but can't copy
this piece so when i copy it the new
piece is shorter than the original piece
and so every time you copy every time
the cell divides the dna gets a little
shorter than it did before
and i say well why is this relevant
because if you make a shorter piece of
dna when you copy it then every time
you're copying it you're interfering
with the genetic code
so it's like well nature would say oh my
god if every time the cell divides
pretty soon i'll chop that dna up and
i'll have a problem but nature of course
being
quite intelligent adds a piece of dna at
the end that is not the gene it's just
an extension it's called a telomere you
may have heard the word telomere and i
say what is it it's an extra railroad
track but it's not the genes and i say
why is it relevant because every time i
copy it i lose a piece of the telomere
but i didn't cut into the genes
and i say well what's aging all about
and here's what we now know aging
depression and disease
result when you copy the dna so many
times that you run out of that track of
telomere and the next time you copy
you're cutting off the gene which
interferes with your biology
so originally it was thought oh the
telomeres have a fixed length and every
time it divides you lose a piece of the
length and the scientists back in the
60s leonard hayflick calculated how many
times can a cell divide before it runs
out of telomere and it came out oh it
was about 50 to 60 cell divisions i say
well why is that relevant because our
stem cells which keep us alive
when they keep dividing what happens
after your stem cells went through 50
cell divisions now your stem cells won't
work anymore and now you can't replace
your cells in your body and that's when
they said oh humans have a given
lifetime
you know 90
100 years at max
and that's your lifetime because that's
when you run out of telomeres
that was very depressing
because it says oh my god if i'm under
stress i actually cut the telomeres even
faster the more stress you're under the
more they disappears
now and it was because of again a woman
scientist because they always come up
with the neat stuff that the men are not
looking at
a woman scientist found there was an
enzyme
an enzyme called telomerase
telo
enzyme telomerase and i say what's that
enzyme it adds the length of the
telomere so as the cells are dividing if
you can activate this enzyme
it will extend the telomeres so the
cells have a relatively unlimited
lifespan
and so the relevance is the belief that
we only live a hundred years is mainly a
consequence of not being able to
continue to extend the telomeres in a
normal person
so they start to find out well what
influences the telomere
well the biggest thing is lack of love
if you don't if you have a lack of love
the feedback will shut off the
telomerase enzyme
if
you have stress in your life
stress shuts off the enzyme
if you have no gratitude
or
appreciation of life it shuts off the
enzyme why well if you don't like life
then why give you an extra life that's
the enzyme is just responding but now it
comes down to the opposites of those
love
and self-love which is most critical
is one of the the big drivers of
telomerase
gratitude
and joy of being in this world enhances
the enzyme why if you love the world you
want more and the cells will give you
more
but now and it's a beautiful question
the most important contributor to
telomerase activity is service
that you are doing something on this
planet you have a mission to do
something and that your nervous system
is telling yourselves i'm not ready to
go i have a job to do
and caregivers for example live an
extraordinarily longer healthier life
than other people why a caregiver's
mentality is i have to service and help
these people and therefore i cannot
leave yet and i have to be healthy
the feedback from the nervous system to
the cells activates telomerase so the
simple line is this
if we have a mission
and we have something to do on this
planet
you will activate telomerase service is
one of the primary things
so it says if you're just meandering
through the earth nice you're going to
end around 90.
but if you're in service to the world
you can extend your life and right now
biologists
somewhat agree that our minimum
lifespan is 140 years
every day there's a battle raging inside
you
the battle is between the comfort
version of yourself and the growth
version of yourself the comfort you
wants to be comfortable doesn't want to
push wants to stay where you are it's
it's difficult it's scary out there
let's stay warm and comfortable
and the growth version of you
wants to grow wants to learn wants to
develop wants to progress wants to serve
wants to help and doing that requires
having courage boldness and jumping into
the unknown and it's a daily battle it's
a daily battle that never goes away and
you have to choose who consistently is
going to win and those daily battles are
not won by doing the big heroic once a
year things it's one by doing the daily
things the daily small things that shift
your identity forward to teach yourself
that you're the growth kind of person
and not the comfort kind of person
the first time i met brendan burchard
was at his event
at growth.com i was speaking in phoenix
it was his event i was one of two guest
speakers it was him and his partner
speaking and then me and eric thomas and
his business partner invited me to come
and speak
and flew me down there and i'd never met
brendan before i knew
i knew of him obviously
but i didn't never met him face to face
and when i when i met him he came
backstage
uh i think it was the day before i was
gonna go speak and i met him backstage
and he said hey i can't i can't wait to
to see you on stage
i almost never bring on guest speakers
who i haven't seen speak before but you
came highly recommended by my business
partner so let's do this and i'm going
to watch your speech
and
see what you do
i have a tv interview that i'm doing and
i'm going to pause that and make sure
i'm done so i can watch your speech
so
in my head there's a lot of stress and
pressure one i never met brendan before
two there's a couple thousand people out
there in the audience
and three usually when speakers are on
stage the other speakers aren't super
paying attention you know they're
backstage in their own world doing their
own thing but brendan was going to end
his interview to make sure that he was
going to watch my speech and so he's
adding all this extra pressure on me
this is the battle of of growth versus
comfort of growth evan versus comfort
evan
my biggest fear disappointing people i
don't want to disappoint him i don't
want to disappoint the person who paid
me to be there i don't want to
disappoint the couple thousand people in
the audience
and so we go through these moments
where
the comfort you takes over the comfort
you wants to play small wants to quit
wants it back down wants to find and out
wants to find an excuse for why you
can't do something and to grow with you
is struggling for control
there's two things that i do
that help growth haven't come out and i
want you to internalize them to apply
them to use them because if you can use
these two strategies it can massively
shift your identity forward help you
become the growth version of you instead
of the comfort version of you and start
giving you the results you want as well
as a more purposeful happy life of
service two things
first one
take on the identity that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things that if
something is scary or difficult or hard
that it's not a good enough reason that
you do scary you do difficult you love
heart
and so i use those as triggers and why
it's important is you shortcut the
thinking pattern every time that you say
that it's scary that's difficult that
it's hard or whatever words that you use
that give yourself a break that let
yourself off the hook use those as
trigger words that the fact that you set
it means you have to do it
the fact that you said it you thought it
you wrote it means you have to do it
just because
what it does is it shortcuts the excuse
because what normally happens is you say
well that's that's too difficult you've
accepted that difficult is a good enough
reason for you to play small you don't
go and do the thing
you've accepted in the excuses that come
into your head over why you can't do it
they're not you don't call them excuses
you call them you call them reasons
right logical valid reasons why you
can't do it
i want to shortcut all that i don't want
to even allow you to go there because i
don't allow myself to go there the fact
that i said scary difficult hards mean i
have to do it
so find your trigger words you can use
mind as a starting point if you want but
find your trigger words
and that becomes your new identity
you want to take on the identity that
you do difficult things
that you you jump into the unknown
that those are no longer good enough
reasons for you and so i did this when i
was backstage when i'm my heart's
beating uh i'm i'm i forgot what i was
gonna say going on stage like in the
moments leading up to going on stage i
forgot what i was gonna say i have no
slides either on stage right i don't go
with a powerpoint presentation there's
one slide that just has my my name and
face on it that's it no slides cause if
i forget what i'm gonna say
i'm kind of screwed
so
breathe
evan carmichael does difficult things i
do difficult things right you remind
yourself what that does is put you into
a more resourceful state to go and
actually solve the problem
so that's step one you do difficult
things and and again it's not just the
big hero moments it's the micro there's
difficult things that have happened
already today that you have not done
what you need to do
because it was difficult and you give
yourself an out go do it
what that does to your self love your
self pride for your self respect for
your self-confidence is incredible
and and you need to give yourself that
gift i want you to give yourself that
gift every day of doing the difficult
thing and for you something that's
difficult may seem trivial or small for
somebody else when i broke my neck and
and was struggling with a concussion
getting out of bed
was difficult
just getting out of bed and putting my
feet on the ground and standing up was
incredible pain through my spine
incredible pain
which is something i take for granted
now but that was difficult
and so when when those things happen you
pat yourself on the back you did it you
did the difficult thing so that's step
number one you do difficult things
the second mindset shift is leaning into
service
it's not even about you
news flash it's not about you
you're here to serve you're here to help
you're you're
for all the ambitions that you have for
yourself whatever the thing is that
you're afraid to do
usually the thing we're afraid to do
is
in front of somebody else you're not
afraid of failing you're afraid of
failing and who's gonna see you fail
[Music]
right you will sing in the shower but
you won't sing on the street corner why
people will film videos
at in in home at their home but not
filming on the street where people can
see them because you're afraid of being
watched
you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of feeling in front of other
people
you need to stop being selfish get out
of your own head
and recognize that you're here to serve
you're here to help
you've got
a message knowledge information that can
help people and by you playing small
you're doing a disservice to them and to
yourself
and so that's the other thing that i'll
lean into
is yeah evan carmichael does difficult
things but also i'm here to serve and so
when i'm backstage and i'm
i know brennan's going to watch me i
know thousands of people are watching me
and i'm afraid of disappointing
everybody i look out into the audience
and instead of seeing 2 000 people who
are here to judge me and i'm going to
disappoint them
i'm here looking at them saying i have a
message that can help them
i'm here to serve them because what i'm
going to share
brendan doesn't know
eric thomas doesn't know the other
speakers here his partners they don't
know i can share something unique that
can help them and my my intention is
good i'm here to help these people not
rip them off not leave them down a dark
path i'm here to help them
and that
again shifts
how you feel about yourself to give you
the courage the boldness the motivation
the power to go and then do the thing
that the growth version of you needs
that's how you get out of the comfort
zone that's how you get out of comfort
you scared you small you into powerful
you bold you courageous you growth you
number one you do difficult things
anytime you find yourself complaining
scary difficult hard negative you do
difficult things and number two you're
here to serve
you're here to serve you're here to help
you're trying to do good and keeping
your gifts to yourself is selfish and
you have to share it and get it out
there
those two things on a daily basis on a
daily basis every single day
that's that battle raging inside your
head between the growth you and the
comfort you
and my ambition my intention my goal for
you
is to have growth you win a little bit
more than comfort you it's not going to
be 100 growth to you there's no way
that's going to happen don't make that
perfection the bar
it's that every day growth you wins at
least 51 of the battles versus comfort
you you do that
your life will change
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know the 60 minutes to start
your day right check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you think about it it's almost
like it's the it's a life thermostat
see in this room right now there's a
thermostat sitting on that wall right
now and if it's set at 75 degrees this
room is going to be regulated to 75
degrees